se trouve donc que j'étais ministre il y
a plus de 10 ans désormais et que j'ai
arrêté toute activité politique depuis
2017 depuis juin 2017 donc vous m'avez
conduite à me replonger dans quelques
archives mais je voudrais dire ici que
si j'avais fait quelques approximations
notamment sur le plan des chiffres je
m'en excuse bien volonté de vous je j'ai
juré solennellement et ce serait donc
uniquement des erreurs de date ou des
erreurs de mémoire
d'autant que l'intégralité de mes
archives y compris nos archives
personnelles sont restés et sont à
disposition ministère donc qui elles
sont parfaitement consultables je
voulais commencer par vous raconter une
anecdote qui je pense est assez
illustratif du sujet sur lequel vous
travaillez
j'ai donc été nommé ministre en 2012
juste après l'élection de François
Hollande et quelques semaines après le
nouveau Président je crois que c'était
son titre du programme investissement
d'avenir tout fraîchement nommé Louis
Gallois demande à me rencontrer
évidemment j'accepte et nous avons un
échange sur la fonction des programmes
investissement d'avenir si vous vous
souvenez c'est un programme lancé par
Nicolas Sarkozy après la crise de 2008
un programme de relance massive et une
partie de ce programme devait être
consacrée à la rénovation thermique des
bâtiments le nouveau président me dit
donc que il y avait un budget de 500
millions d'euros consacré à la
rénovation thermique des
habitations des plus démunis et que
malencontreusement ce programme faisait
l'objet d'une sous consommation massive
puisque 5 millions seulement avait été
engagés et que donc il souhaitait
m'informer que
dans le cadre de leur réflexion il
souhaitait réattribuer le reliquat soit
49 millions d'euros à Airbus vous
imaginez que la toute nouvelle ministre
du Logement qui plus est écologiste a eu
un petit moment de fraîcheur à l'annonce
de cette disposition et je vais
expliquer que ça allait pas être
possible que je pensais que c'était une
erreur mais que quand même il y avait un
sujet sur cette sous-consommation après
enquête et je résume à gros trait la
sous-consommation s'expliquait assez
naturellement puisque les publics
visaient par ce programme devait
répondre au plafond plaiste à dire
environ 60% du SMIC là encore je vous
dis de mémoire donc on va dire donc des
plafonds assez bas mais pour des
montants de travaux très importants de
lors d'une trentaine de milliers d'euros
donc on comprend très volo très
rapidement que engager des travaux de
plus de 30000 euros quand on a comme
revenu moins de 60% du SMIC forcément
c'est très compliqué
à la suite de ça j'ai organisé une
rencontre avec l'ensemble des
intervenants dans ce domaine là dont les
régions qui étaient mobilisées assez
largement je rappelle qu'à l'époque
c'était avant la réforme il y avait
beaucoup plus de régions qu'aujourd'hui
pour un échange assez intéressant dans
lequel autour de la table chaque
représentante en du monde HLM que de
l'Association des régions de France que
de l'ensemble des élus que
les responsables de l'ADEME de la NA
tout le monde explique que tout va
parfaitement bien que tout est
parfaitement en ordre et chacun déroule
on va dire le grand talent avec lequel
ils ont mis en oeuvre des politiques je
leur explique qu'il y a quand même un
sujet c'est que tout semble parfait mais
que visiblement ça marche pas c'est pour
résumer ce qui a été à le guide de mon
action comme ministre pendant ces deux
années et ce qui a fait l'objet donc
d'une première annonce si je ne me
trompe pas en janvier 2013 de ce que
devait être une évolution de des
manières d'intervenir en matière de
rénovation thermique c'est-à-dire non
seulement de mobiliser de l'argent mais
surtout de simplifier et à cet instant
je veux dire que je crois qu'un des
principaux handicaps et donc je vais
donc devancer votre votre question c'est
le morcellement des acteurs en charge du
dossier ça c'est le premier point c'est
qu'il y a beaucoup de d'initiatives qui
sont bonnes mais il y a un morcellement
très grand et puis surtout une capacité
de la part de certains acteurs privés à
utiliser de manière très opportuniste
des dispositifs qui en eux-mêmes
notamment les crédits d'impôts peuvent
être intéressant mais qui ont parfois
fait l'objet d'utilisation complètement
détournée ce qui a conduit le
législateur notamment au moment de
l'examen des lois de finances à chaque
fois à être très prudent puisque chaque
parlementaire avait des témoignages
d'abus qui s'appuyait sur des
démarchages parfois un peu agressifs de
personnes dont on isolait dont on change
les fenêtres alors que le toit n'était
pas isolé par exemple ce qui est sur un
plan énergétique parfaitement absurde
donc ce morcellement plus des
dispositifs conçus de manière
je sais pas quel est le bon adjectif
mais
désordonné peut-être qui chacun prit
individuellement pouvait avoir du sens
mais qui n'était pas coordonnées
conduisait aux résultats qu'on
connaît et qu'on connaît d'ailleurs pour
une part toujours c'est-à-dire
une grande limite dans la capacité à
mettre en œuvre un programme de
rénovation thermique
j'ai donc fini par obtenir une sorte de
pacte politique avec le Premier ministre
qui était et donc je réponds aussi la
part anticipation à votre question
est-ce que c'était un outil d'être
ministre de pleine exercice oui d'être
ministre de plein exercice et oui
d'avoir du poids politique j'avais du
poids politique pour deux raisons un je
représentais le seul parti partenaire
presque de la coalition politique qui
existait alors et par ailleurs j'avais
un entraînement particulier qui est que
vous avez pas appelé que j'étais
secrétaire national du parti écologiste
pendant six ans ce qui je pense est fait
partie des meilleurs écoles de
l'entraînement au rapport de force que
qui puisse exister sur le marché de la
politique et que je conseille à tout le
monde mais si j'en crois les autres
personnes que vous allez auditionner
cette école a formé un panel politique
qui maintenant va sur l'ensemble du
spectre politique français quasiment
sans exclusion donc je crois que c'est
une bonne école donc je le dis un mini
de plein exercice une capacité au
rapport de politique au rapport de force
politique et la possibilité obtenir des
arbitrages temps en terme
organisationnel qu'en terme financier
parce que et ce sera la clé du
dispositif et l'histoire assez rapide
puisque dès 2014 les choses se sont
gâtées à montrer que en mettant en
cohérence le dispositif en abondant de
manière extrêmement significative les
fonds de la NA ça avait très bien
fonctionné ça a très bien fonctionné et
pendant très peu de temps puisque comme
et donc là je tiens à le dire de manière
la plus ferme qui soit entre les
annonces financières et la réalité des
crédits notamment du fait des gels qui
sont opérés de l'été souvent par Bercy
vous avez des situations de crispation
et en regardant mes archives j'ai
retrouvé le nombre de questions y
compris d'ailleurs de vos collègues
sénateurs de question écrite ou de
questions orales de chaque sénateur qui
interroge sur son territoire et sur son
département le fait que il y avait plein
de dossiers en attente et en souffrance
dans les tiroirs de Lana parce qu'il y
avait simplement plus donc l'année 2014
a été très marquante donc pour tout dire
le pacte que j'avais avec le Premier
ministre était simple c'était un montant
très important et si ça marchait
d'abonder ce montant il se trouve que
j'ai quitté le gouvernement pour des
raisons qui n'ont pas avoir avec le
programme de rénovation énergétique mais
d'autres raisons politiques que cet
argent a été très bien dépensé très vite
dépensé beaucoup plus vite que ce qui
était prévu et que au lieu d'être abondé
mais le changement de Premier ministre
est donc obligé il a été il n'a pas fait
l'objet d'abondement et ça a été très
bien dit d'ailleurs notamment par
Valérie létharc qui a été présidente de
Lana et qui connaît parfaitement le
sujet c'est que la restriction de ces
crédits doublés du fait de la baisse
après le brexit du prix du carbone qui a
fait aussi baisser les ressources de
Lana et malgré un amendement pris de 50
millions si je me trompe pas sur le
budget de ce qui devait s'appeler déjà
Action Logement ou je ne sais pas encore
enfin des crédits de feu 1% logement
les crédits de la nana n'étaient pas
suffisants pour suivre les engagements
qui avaient été pris
l'autre élément qui avait rendu la chose
très facileitatrice était le fait de
créer un guichet unique par le biais
d'un numéro de téléphone et d'obliger
l'ensemble des acteurs toutes les
collectivités locales et les différents
acteurs à
donner leurs données et renvoyer
l'ensemble des interlocuteurs et
notamment des personnes physiques vers
un seul guichet donc oui bien sûr cette
ce morcellement et la complexité rend
extrêmement périlleux le montage de ces
dossiers pour moi il n'y a pas besoin
d'aller chercher plus loin nous
disposons des professionnels et des
professionnels formés nous disposons
aussi de leur capacité à monter en
charge si c'était nécessaire mais il y a
un vrai sujet d'effet de levier qui est
celui permis par la mobilisation
d'argent public lequel argent public est
extrêmement bien utilisé à deux titres
alors nous faisons peu ce genre d'études
en France mais l'étude dont je vous
parle est assez ancienne mais les
Britanniques qui évaluaient les
économies en matière de financement de
l'assurance maladie enfin l'équivalent
de l'Assurance Maladie de
l'investissement dans la rénovation
thermique notamment pour ce qui est des
personnes âgées parce qu'on sait très
bien que la précarité énergétique
au-delà des conséquences sociales de
confort à des conséquences sur la santé
significatif et que donc c'est
investissement peut être compensé par
des économies alors je sais qu'on fait
peu ses études et il se trouve que
depuis presque 5 ans maintenant je
travaille dans une organisation qui a
une culture anglo-saxonne donc ça ne
choque moins que ça pourrait choquer des
Français mais sur le bon usage de
l'argent public de voir effectivement ce
que ça peut coûter comme argent mais ce
que ça économise au-delà de l'aspect
moral et satisfaisant d'avancer vers
davantage de justice sociale c'est très
intéressant l'autre élément c'est que
c'est aussi un investissement d'argent
public très rentable puisque les travaux
de rénovation thermique sont une
activité parfaitement
non délocalisable et qui fourni de
l'emploi local donc je ne saurais pas
évalué et je ne sais pas s'il existe des
études publiées sur l'impact d'un euro
d'argent public investi dans la
rénovation thermique en création de
richesse et en diminution du chômage
mais je suis sûr qu'elle serait forte
intéressante à conduire parce qu'elles
sont à mon avis très marquantes autre
élément très important je crois le recul
qui a été pris dans l'investissement des
collectivités locales parce que
évidemment la question des bâtiments et
des logements est importante mais la
question du tertiaire et notamment des
bâtiments publics dans le respect du
patrimoine et dans le respect des
prérogatives des architectes des
bâtiments de France mais néanmoins de
façon très volontariste et pour moi
aussi un élément clé de de levier très
utile et qui a été sous-utilisé là aussi
j'ai mémoire d'une réunion de discussion
extrêmement vive sur l'investissement de
la Caisse des Dépôts possibles pour
aider les collectivités locales à
conduire une vraie politique
d'économie d'énergie un peu plus large
mais aussi de rénovation de leur
patrimoine il faut savoir que beaucoup
de collectivités locales possèdent des
bâtiments construits dans la pire
période la pire période n'étant pas
celle qui est autour de nous mais les
années 70-80 qui ont conduit à
j'ai fâché les années 70 et 80
qui ont conduit à une production de
consommateur
consommateur d'énergie parfois y compris
avec des systèmes de chauffage qui sont
des systèmes de chauffage eux aussi très
très énergivores donc le la conjonction
de ces deux phénomènes à mon point de
vue était un frein important pourquoi
j'en tire une expérience
nuancée d'abord parce que ça s'est
arrêté mais parce que ça a marché c'est
à dire que pendant une cour période il y
a eu vraiment un effet considérable au
sein de Lana alors je pense que vous
pourriez avec intérêt
convié les personnes de Lana qui était
présente à cette époque parce qu'elles
ont un souvenir sans doute plus précis
que le mien mais si je retrouve les
chiffres les le bilan qui avait été tiré
au bout d'un an était très très positif
parce qu'il y avait une appétence forte
et je pense que en le disant presque 10
ans après malheureusement il y aura une
appétence encore beaucoup plus
importante
cette rénovation thermique notamment des
bâtiments des particuliers n'est pas
possible sans l'effet de levier de du
financement public je le crois d'abord à
ce qu'il est un outil de motivation
ensuite parce que il y a un écart entre
le taux d'investissement nécessaire et
le taux de rentabilité qui peut être
beaucoup trop long pour un certain
nombre de personnes physiques ça n'est
pas le cas je le dis pour les personnes
morales que ce soit les entreprises d'où
la question du tertiaire ou les
collectivités locales mais pour les
propriétaires personnes physiques c'est
plus compliqué je pense qu'il y a deux
angles morts
le premier angle mort c'est celui des
propriétaire bailleur le dispositif qui
permet de contribuer aux travaux
d'économie d'énergie en échange de du
conventionnement anna est un bon
dispositif de mon point de vue mais il
serait beaucoup plus efficace s'il était
plus contraignant alors les avancées
législatives vont sans doute le
permettre mais je crains un angle mort
actuel
et là je fais quoi un débat qui était un
débat vif à l'époque ce débat a été
résolu entre les organisations de
protection de l'environnement qui
étaient très volontariste sur l'éviction
des passoires thermiques de
l'autorisation de location enfin de les
faire rentrer dans le décret d'essence
qui va arriver avec les logements de
type G mais avec du coup un risque et je
le vois là je puisque votre commission
travaille aujourd'hui je me permets
cette petite alerte c'est à dire que la
vente massive de logement
qui sont plus possibles d'être loués et
qui vont être rachetés uniquement par
des gens qui auront les moyens de
pouvoir investir pour faire ces travaux
pour louer donc pas forcément à un tarif
très intéressant et avec une
concentration du patrimoine locatif qui
est déjà très identifié qui a été très
identifié par l'INSEE et qui à mon avis
est un problème qui dépasse le problème
de la rénovation énergétique mais je
pense qu'en matière de logement et j'y
reviendrai avoir une vision globale des
enjeux et pas de manière sectorisée
entre le prix des loyers le prix du
foncier
la consommation thermique des bâtiments
me paraît être absolument nécessaire
puisque quand on parle de logement on
touche à un sujet qui relève des besoins
fondamentaux de l'être humain comme
boire ou manger on a besoin d'un abri je
crois que
l'intervention de la puissance publique
sur ces sujets et absolument essentiels
dernier élément que je voulais apporter
à votre réflexion
les embarder divers et variés l'absence
de Constance
alors je crois que les objectifs sont
toujours annoncés en étant les mêmes
mais qui sont jamais tenus et donc je
trouve ça très intéressant que vous vous
posiez la question de savoir pourquoi
ils sont pas tenus ils sont pas tenus là
en l'occurrence les objectifs qu'ils
avaient que j'avais annoncé en tant que
ministre ils ont pas été tenus parce que
l'amendement qui avait été promis entre
guillemets par le Premier ministre s'il
dispositif fonctionnel n'a pas été mise
en oeuvre et donc il y a de fait une
restriction et quand vous aboutissez je
pense que ces embarder sont aussi Natura
freiner durablement parce que les gens
pensent que ça va marcher plus que ça va
pas marcher et comme ça demande beaucoup
d'énergie de monter un dossier et
beaucoup de complexité vous avez une
perte en ligne qui est considérable et
au fil des années un épuisement des
acteurs et ça je pense que c'est quelque
chose de nouveau je pense qu'il peut y
avoir un épuisement des acteurs de tous
ceux qui travaillent dans ce domaine du
fait de cette complexité pour s'attaquer
à ce sujet je suis maintenant assez
convaincue qu'il est absolument
nécessaire d'avoir un service public de
la rénovation énergétique
qui est capable d'être un guichet unique
notamment des différents financements
possibles par les différentes
collectivités locales mais aussi
Egyptiens là de fournir une expertise en
matière
énergétique qui soit une expertise
honnête
bien sûr si vous
n'avez pas
une vraie objectivité sur la
priorisation des travaux effectués dans
un logement vous pouvez aboutir à des
aberrations et une dépense d'argent qui
n'aura pas d'effet sur les économies
d'énergie et ça c'est donc quel a été la
réponse du législateur de supprimer tout
un tas de crédits d'impôts ce qui était
positif dans un sens à éviter des abus
négatifs dans un autre parce que ça
pouvait être parfaitement utile donc je
pense qu'il faut qu'il y a une vision
beaucoup plus
[Musique]
partagée d'un vrai diagnostic et d'une
priorisation des travaux parce que et là
aussi donc une pierre dans le jardin des
écologistes
mes débats de ministres ont été
difficiles avec certaines associations
écologistes qui considéraient que or une
rénovation globale qui aboutissait à un
niveau Bâtiment Basse Consommation
point de salut au sens où de gagner
quelques
pas étaient pas suffisant j'entends sur
un plan théorique que je l'entends bien
mais pour certains c'était en fait le
résultat c'était rien
l'objection justifiée était dire que
certains travaux qui apparaissaient
comme des travaux de rénovation
énergétique j'ai donné tout à l'heure
cet exemple des fenêtres quand le toit
est pas isolé c'était absurde c'est vrai
c'est pour ça que je pense que le
diagnostic énergétique préalable fait de
manière objective et sans que ce soit
ensuite celui qui a intérêt à faire les
travaux qui fassent ce diagnostic et à
mon avis absolument décisif donc et je
fais le lien avec la loi alur beaucoup
ont reproché
les abus de diagnostic préalable aux
ventes de logement je pense que s'ils
sont bien faits c'est au contraire très
utile parce que avant
oui oui bien sûr je pense que avant
pardon excusez-moi
on faisait
acquérir des biens à des personnes qui
passeront des comptes au bout de
quelques mois qu'en fait elle pouvait
tout simplement pas payer le chauffage
de leur de leur habitation qui se
retrouvait surendettée des dans les
semaines ou les mois qui suivaient leur
acquisition en n'ayant pas eu
connaissance du tout de l'ensemble de
ces éléments et que quand vous engagez à
acheter un bien il y a évidemment le
coup du prêt mais il y a bien d'autres
dépenses qui n'étaient pas du tout
évaluées je le rappelle avant la loi
alur donc au titre des fiertés et je le
dis de manière très très modeste parce
que c'est recommandations n'étaient pas
ne sont pas sortis de de mon cerveau
mettez l'objet avait fait l'objet de
rapport parlementaire et de proposition
d'un certain nombre de parlementaires
tant à l'Assemblée qu'au Sénat je pense
que c'est ce sont de bonnes avancées
mais que maintenant il faut aller un pas
plus loin et je pense que or ce guichet
unique or cette interlocuteur simple on
n'arrivera pas à massifier les objectifs
de rénovation thermique le deuxième
élément c'est un élément de utilisation
financière donc je sais que c'est plus à
la mode les lois de programmation
sauf quand elles sont dans un cas de
militaire mais je pense que si on veut
lancer des grands travaux qui perdent
nous permettent à la fois à la
transition énergétique et de essayer de
tenir notre
SNBC mais aussi de pouvoir se préparer à
l'adaptation nécessaire à laquelle nous
allons devoir faire face du fait du
changement climatique il faut absolument
une loi de programmation qui sécurise
pour l'ensemble des acteurs comme pour
les particuliers
une trajectoire dans la durée je suis
absolument résolue parce que l'échec de
ce qui a été annoncé par la ministre
Cécile Duflot en 2013 il est écrit dans
une réponse à une question
au Sénat que je vais vous retrouver qui
dit de manière très claire que les
crédits de la de Lana ont été gelés au
mois de juin de l'année 2014
et que du coup les objectifs qui avaient
été affichés même les dossiers qui
existaient dans les tiroirs de Lana ne
pouvait pas être mise en oeuvre donc
voilà c'est finalement assez simple ça
semble complexe c'est pas si complexe
mais comme toutes les politiques
d'ampleur je pense qu'elle nécessite
une organisation qui soit simplifiée et
une visibilité dans la durée de la même
manière que quand on investit dans un
grand programme industriel on fait un
scénario d'investissement sur plusieurs
années étonnamment l'État qui
normalement est là pour le restant de
nos jours n'est pas capable de le faire
et je pense que c'est une faute et une
erreur c'est pas tellement le fait de
des ministres qui sont succédés à cette
responsabilité peut-être
alors elle a été elle est elle est
toujours fin alors pour le coup vous
vous êtes dans une politique où tout le
monde est d'accord je pense qu'il y a
des politiques qui peuvent faire des
balles encadrement des loyers on
pourrait avoir un débat sur la
rénovation thermique des bâtiments tout
le monde est d'accord donc pourquoi une
politique où tout le monde est d'accord
où tout le monde dit que c'est bien on
n'arrive pas à mettre en oeuvre votre
commission intéressante moi je peux vous
le dire parce qu'on tient pas dans la
durée sur l'argent et oui je le dis le
pilotage budgétaire ce qui est ma
surprise moi je ne je n'ai pas j'ai
travaillé uniquement dans le secteur
privé avant de rejoindre un poste de
ministre et
j'ai été très surprise de la dimension
cours thermiste avec laquelle et piloté
le budget d'un grand pays comme la
France et je dois le dire mes
discussions budgétaires avec les
différents ministres du Budget ont
toujours été parfois
désespérante la norme de dépenses
puisque c'est comme ça qui convient de
parler étant la chose la plus stupide
que j'ai connue dans ma vie parce que
quand vous avez vous êtes capable de
prouver qu'un investissement d'un euro
d'argent public peut rapporter 1,3 euros
d'argent public à échéance 5 ans
n'importe quel investisseur n'importe
lequel signe dans la seconde n'importe
lequel sauf l'état sauf l'État et je le
dis les règles budgétaires telles
qu'elles sont mises en oeuvre
aujourd'hui dans la loi de finances me
semble dans un certain nombre de cas
complètement absurde contre-productive
et
finalement assez rageante et le bilan
que je retire sur cette politique là et
assez rageant
vous me permettrez d'avoir la franchise
qui m'était déjà coutumière à l'époque
mais qui s'est enrichi de mon
éloignement de de vos cercles
parlementaires le contexte de l'enjeu et
y compris les questions que vous posez
et qui sont tout à fait légitimes sur la
difficulté sur le pourquoi les quels
sont les raisons de
d'une politique sur la rénovation qui
semble être en échec je pense que déjà
il faut bien se rendre compte que c'est
la politique la plus difficile en
matière de logement parce qu'on
s'attaque au stock on s'attaque au stock
donc un volume de bâti dans l'ensemble
de son hétérogénéité collectif comme
individuel bâtiments récents comme
bâtiment extrêmement ancien en plus dans
un pays où le poids du bâtiment ancien
d'avant la Première Guerre mondiale
reste important à ce qui n'est pas
exactement la même chose si vous
comparez avec d'autres pays européens et
puis s'attaquer au stock ça veut dire
que on s'attaque donc au logement
existant et donc on s'attaque à la vie
des gens et je crois que ça explique
aussi une des difficultés qui est que
vous rentrez dans la vie de particulier
à la à l'aune de ces questions sur le la
réhabilitation et ce qui veut dire aussi
que même si évidemment il y a une partie
des logements détenus par des bailleurs
sociaux donc des propriétaires massifs
des foncières mais beaucoup de logements
sont devenus par les particuliers ça
veut dire il faudrait un accompagnement
énorme pour pouvoir faire quelque chose
avec eux et ça explique aussi la
difficulté
et parfois l'échec de certaines
politiques
il me semble il me semble important de
d'y répondre parce que c'est vrai qu'on
porte beaucoup d'attention sur les
enjeux de production nouvelles sur les
enjeux de la crise du logement mais
traiter le stock de logements existant
pose évidemment des questions bien plus
difficiles quel bilan je peux faire de
mon passage alors au gouvernement tout
d'abord je pense important de le
contextualiser parce que moi je suis
arrivée en fin de mandat et y compris en
étant nommé en 2016 je savais que mon
mandat n'irait de toute façon pas plus
loin que la fin du mandat du président
de la République donc mon équipe et moi
même avion et c'était d'ailleurs la
volonté du gouvernement à l'époque des
objectifs très clairs qui étaient
l'application des textes de loi et
notamment la publication des décrets
d'application alors vous avez parlé de
la loi de la transition énergétique pour
la croissance verte mais il y avait
aussi la loi alur quand je suis arrivé
il y avait plus de 200 décrits encore à
prendre et c'est vrai que nous avons
cherché à mettre en application un
certain nombre de ces textes mais aussi
répondre d'ailleurs à des missions
d'information qui étaient déjà en cours
sur ces textes de loi ce qui explique
aussi que j'ai certes réorienté
certaines politiques mais je n'avais pas
exactement le même positionnement que
les ministres que les ministres
passaient même si j'ai par ailleurs
publié enfin travailler un autre texte
de loi qui a été soyé mais qui était pas
sur les mêmes sur les mêmes sujets
et par ailleurs en tout cas au moment où
j'arrive au gouvernement on a évidemment
les enjeux de rénovation mais on a aussi
d'autres préoccupations et qui sont
évidemment le soutien à la production
nouvelle de logement qui était vraiment
le coeur de la politique de l'époque
logement privé comme logements sociaux
l'éradication de l'habitat insalubre
et vous le savez madame la sénastricht
c'était rapporteur de mon texte de loi
j'ai échoué puisqu'en fait on voulait
prendre une ordonnance sur le sujet et
que elle n'a pas été prise et ça ça a
été fait plus tard dans le quinquennat
suivant c'était un enjeu extrêmement
fort toute la question en fait de la
précarité énergétique et qui est pas
seulement lié à la rénovation mais qui
était vraiment de travailler sur les
publics les plus en difficulté et puis
une volonté aussi de moderniser la
profession parce qu'on était un stade
aussi on avait des tas d'enjeux sur les
garanties autour de la profession dans
le bâtiment des enjeux de cartes
professionnelles de fraude à l'emploi de
fraude à la TVA et vous le savez sur les
sujets particuliers de la mise en place
de la du label RGE et puis par ailleurs
lorsque j'étais ministre j'avais aussi
des enjeux extrêmement forts sur de la
mise en place de nouveaux dispositifs
l'encadrement des loyers le permis de
louer c'est des décrets que nous avons
pris début 2016 et aussi des
mobilisations sur des sujets locaux sur
lesquels Premier ministre de l'époque
m'avait demandé de travailler beaucoup
la question de l'habitat insalubre et
indigne à Marseille et la revitalisation
du bassin minier avec notamment des
enjeux de rénovation extrêmement
importantes mais qui était en soi des
politiques très fortes et qui n'étaient
pas d'ailleurs dans les dans les sujets
dont on va parler dont on va parler
après tout ça pour vous dire que
évidemment il y avait un enjeu très fort
sur la rénovation mais qu'il était
inscrit dans une politique logement plus
globale et après pour dire les choses
très franchement oui moi j'ai fait
partie d'un gouvernement qui affichait
ses objectifs qui a fixé des objectifs
de construction de logements
de production de logements sociaux et
d'un objectif de 500 000 rénovations
avec évidemment quand vous fixez un
objectif en tant que gouvernement vous
mettez en difficulté puisque vous donnez
les moyens à vos adversaires comme à vos
partenaires de dire vous ne les faites
pas oui mais au moins on avait un
objectif et je pense que c'est
extrêmement important justement de
travailler ainsi parce que même si un
objectif vous n'arrivez pas à
l'atteindre au moins vous en avez donné
un et vous dites que le qu'il est là
alors on l'a vu d'ailleurs sur la
question de la production de logements
sociaux que ne pas vouloir donner
d'objectifs on voit ce que ça donne
derrière mais c'est pareil pour la
rénovation assumez même si on n'y arrive
pas qu'il fallait faire 500 000
logements
rénovés dont après la moitié en va dire
programme Habiter mieux c'est ce qui a
été écrit en fait dans la loi de 2015
c'est aussi dire que le curseur il doit
être là et je pense que ça permet aussi
de donner à voir de ce qu'on devrait
faire et moi j'ai aucun problème à
assumer qu'on a mis des objectifs et que
ensuite ben oui on répond et vous on a
des chiffres et ils sont pas toujours
bons et c'est évidemment un regret mais
moi je n'ai aucun regret d'avoir assumé
un cap et d'avoir dit qu'on n'était pas
au niveau au moins c'est de la
transparence et ça permet me semble-t-il
aussi travaillé mais y compris d'avoir
des vrais débats sur les questions
budgétaires parce qu'en effet avec cet
objectif là et il est moyen
d'accompagnement qui sont nécessaires on
verra que en effet on n'avait pas tous
les moyens budgétaires nécessaires mais
j'y reviendrai parce que c'est pas
qu'une question d'argent qui explique à
mon avis qu'on n'est pas totalement
au niveau je pense que ce que cette
audition m'a permis aussi de réfléchir
quelques années plus tard je parce qu'on
n'est pas sorti des difficultés
aujourd'hui même si je parlerai un peu
du présent et c'est vrai que je pense
qu'il y a quand même des débats qu'on a
toujours pas tranché et d'ailleurs vous
les posez dans vos questions qui doit-on
aider
est-ce qu'on est tout le monde et on
veut matifier est-ce qu'on cherche à
aider les publics des décides de revenus
les plus les plus faibles ou alors
est-ce qu'il faudrait se regarder
vraiment les plus gros émetteurs de gaz
à effet de serre pour aider eux en
premier et les forcer eux
ensuite il y a une deuxième idée qui à
mon avis continue à être fausse et je
pense que c'est une difficulté c'est que
cette idée que la rénovation d'un
logement peut se faire à budget constant
et que finalement ça tourne tout seul et
je pense que c'est ça le noeud du
problème moi je ne crois toujours pas
qu'il y a un modèle économique de la
rénovation ça veut pas dire qu'il faut
pas le faire mais propose sont très
claires je pense que c'est essentiel
qu'on progresse sur les rénovations des
logements comme des bâtiments mais le
modèle économique il est extrêmement
difficile sur le logement social il
existe pas vraiment mais c'est pas
l'enjeu d'aujourd'hui chez les
particuliers je vous dirais ça dépend un
peu de l'orage vous avez beaucoup de
public retraités propriétaires qui vous
disent aujourd'hui qu'il ne voit pas
l'intérêt de prendre de faire des
travaux extrêmement coûteux sur lesquels
ils n'auront pas de retour
d'investissement et on peut leur faire
miroiter l'idée que ils vont vendre
mieux leurs biens à terme c'est même pas
vrai partout en réalité ça dépend
beaucoup de l'attractivité du marché
immobilier ça dépend où il est situé
qu'on voit bien là sur l'augmentation
des des passoires mises en vente qu'en
fait il y a des territoires où elles se
vendent pas moins cher donc faut voir
évidemment extrêmement attention à ça et
d'autant plus et je pense que c'est
peut-être aussi une de nos faiblesses
qui est qu'aujourd'hui des particuliers
qui investissent pour rénover leur
logement qui donc font baisser les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre de
leur logement donc ils investissent
peut-être qu'ils vont retrouver un
retour d'investissement évidemment sur
le consommation d'énergie leur coûte
l'énergie et peut-être sur la vente de
leur patrimoine mais
ils n'ont jamais été en fait remerciés
entre guillemets incité par l'État pour
avoir baissé leur part des missions
carbone quand vous achetez aujourd'hui
une voiture peu émettrice vous avez une
réduction de votre carte grise vous avez
donc quand même un incitation vous
rénovez votre logement est-ce que vous
avez des incitations sur vos différentes
taxes et pourquoi je vous dis ça c'est
parce que le fait de ne pas donner de
prix au carbone et donc de ne pas donner
de prix aux économies des émissions de
carbone ça rend aussi le dossier d'aut
plus d'autant plus difficile après
je veux je dois quand même dire que
en tout cas la preuve de ce modèle
économique n'existe pas vraiment et
peut-être que ça doit pas nous arrêter
pour faire c'est à dire que et peut-être
que c'est ça qui nous permettrait de
vraiment arriver à des objectifs de
rénovation important c'est que justement
on construise une substitution un modèle
économique qui n'existe pas pour qu'en
fait la dépense portée par les
particuliers ou même pour les bailleurs
sociaux soit en fait acceptable et on
pourrait jouer sur des emprunts long
terme sur des subventions
parce qu'évidemment il y a un coût pour
l'État de ne pas baisser ses émissions
carbone très clairement et par rapport
aux stratégies nationales bas carbone
actuelle et futur et les engagements
européens mais je pense que ça explique
évidemment une des difficultés et un des
nœuds du problème parce que en tout cas
dans le cas qui est dans lequel j'étais
une de nos grosses difficultés c'était
d'avoir plus d'argent et un budget
constant sur les enjeux de la rénovation
et j'y reviendrai notamment dans le
cadre du budget de Lana parce que
c'était un enjeu particulier mais
au-delà de ça je dois aussi dire que des
choses qui n'ont d'ailleurs pas beaucoup
changé la faiblesse des partenaires
bancaires sur le sujet parce que très
clairement pour le logement social
heureusement la Caisse des dépôts est
présente et travail toujours à des prêts
qui accompagnent au long cours et y
compris continue d'innover avec
l'ensemble des bailleurs sociaux sur le
sujet mais on n'a pas un acteur bancaire
de la rénovation comme il existe dans
d'autres pays européens qui pourraient
être un partenaire bancaire privilégié
pour des des particuliers ou des
propriétaires de quelques lots je le dis
parce que c'est un des freins importants
y compris pour des ménages qui étaient
concernés par le programme habité mieux
mais qui était dans la partie la plus
haute de ces ménages fragiles et qui
avait un reste à d'emprunt
beaucoup de dossiers bloqués beaucoup de
difficultés à l'époque j'ai eu des
beaucoup discussions avec les
partenaires bancaires et je peux vous
dire pour une un résultat assez médiocre
sur leur mobilisation sur leur facilité
sur l'acceptation de financer ces
dossiers enfin dans les dans les
difficultés qui existaient à l'époque et
qui expliquent une partie de l'échec et
qui sont toujours là c'est le régime de
la copropriété
qui est très clairement pas adapté à
cette accélération des travaux à cette
massification et même si on a fait des
progrès collectifs très importants ce
régime a été changé à plusieurs reprises
on a créé le fonds travaux on a
énormément travaillé travailler sur les
sujets les plus ardues je pense
évidemment aux copropriétés dégradées la
création quand même des Orcades oyennes
suite quand même au travail considérable
qui avait été fait par le sénateur
Claudine c'est extrêmement important de
se rappeler ça parce qu'on part vraiment
de très loin avant le travail du
sénateurs Seine-Saint-Denis franchement
on avait des outils totalement pas au
niveau aujourd'hui les encodes de Yen il
y en a énormément qui ont été créés et
c'est vraiment une solution mais là on
parle des copro très très dégradés la
question c'est le reste des régimes de
copropriété et de la difficulté à faire
voter des travaux et à intéresser
l'ensemble des bailleurs pour pour les
aider alors c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui là
après cette année d'un tarif de
l'énergie extrêmement cher et un peu fou
vous allez me dire bah le modèle
économique on le voit très bien qu'on
est arrivé de l'énergie extrêmement
extrêmement fort mais moi si je me
rappelle les années 2015-2016 on n'est
pas du tout dans le même niveau on est
dans un tarif de l'énergie extrêmement
bas
une sorte de très grandes difficultés à
convaincre les ménages que c'est bon
pour leur pouvoir d'achat de faire des
travaux à l'avenir et et objectivement
une difficulté d'enclencher les choses
bon néanmoins beaucoup de choses ont été
faites
d'une part il y a eu quand même des
modifications législatives importantes
alors il y a l'ensemble des dispositifs
de la loi transition
énergétique pour la croissance verte je
vais pas revenir surtout puis je pense
que vous aurez vous aurez des questions
mais l'idée était quand même d'essayer
alors à l'époque c'était assorti d'un
crédit d'impôt d'une part pour les
ménages qui payaient des impôts et puis
le renforcement du programme habité
mieux qui maintenant si j'ai bien
compris s'appelle ma prime rénov
sérénité mais bon habiter mieux voilà
qui était pour les ménages les plus
modestes avec vraiment des subventions
et un portage assez maximum pour les
ménages les plus pauvres et puis des
aides pour des ménages qui vous pouvez
aussi emprunter une partie une partie de
de comment dire de des travaux je pense
que la très grande difficulté dans cette
période là c'est en fait sur comment
comment est construit les programmes de
rénovation donc on a cette cet outil
formidable qui est la nana l'agence
nationale d'amélioration de l'habitat je
le dis ici qui est un outil qui nous est
envié moi quand j'étais ministre j'étais
sollicitée à plusieurs reprises par les
milieux logement en Allemagne et dans
d'autres pays européens mais aussi parce
qu'on avait posé la question aquito j'ai
fait beaucoup de rencontres avec des
délégations étrangères qui voulaient
tous savoir ce que c'était que cette
agence nationale et comment était-il
possible que l'État investisse pour
l'habitat c'était quand même très
intéressant et c'est comme l'enrue qui
est quand même un modèle intéressant
mais Lana contrairement à l'enrue n'a
pas de capacité à engager des fonds de
manière plus réelle et c'est bien le
projet bien le problème
alors rue sur les programmes de
rénovation urbaine on est sur une
programmation à 10 ans avec donc on
décaisse pas on programme des dépenses
budgétaires qui sont assort de maquette
financière et après dans des comités
d'engagement puis après il y a du
décaissement par dépenses Lana c'est une
agence mais le problème c'est que chaque
année son volume de dossier à gérer et à
faire entre eux alors à l'époque habité
mieux les logements qui étaient adaptés
je sais plus comment ça s'appelait mais
donc l'adaptation des logements et puis
les autres programmes c'est des volumes
de dossiers que la NAS doit ensuite
répartir au niveau
territorial et en fait ça dépend du
niveau budgétaire qui qui est fixé et
c'est une des difficultés parce qu'à
plusieurs reprises et y compris avant
2012 ça a été tout le problème y compris
sous le quinquennat précédent 2012 Lana
en fonction des consommations bonnes ou
pas bonnes des dossiers se retrouvaient
en cours d'année soit arrêté de financer
les dossiers soit les bloquer et comme
c'était des dossiers en co-financement
que les collectivités territoriales plus
avec les opérateurs associatifs qui
faisaient l'accompagnement social on
s'est retrouvés avec quand même une
construction de méfiance très forte
entre les opérateurs et la NAS sur
est-ce que vraiment comme vous me dites
vous allez faire je suis pas mille
dossiers dans tel collectivité est-ce
que vraiment vous allez me financer les
1000 dans l'année
sauf que c'est tellement long de porter
un dossier de rénovation pour un public
précaire entre l'accompagnement social
le montage des dossier de subventions la
sollicitation des collectivités locales
des différentes aides que quand vous
apprenez huit mois plus tard que le
dossier finalement n'est pas financé que
on attend l'année prochaine en fait ça
s'arrête et je pense que ça reste une
très grande difficulté pour ces dossiers
là ou en fait on a on n'a pas une
capacité à dire qu'on construit quelque
chose de plus réelle donc ça veut dire
aussi qu'on change la manière de
construire le budget de Lana et le débat
budgétaire autour et qui permettrait
certainement de pas connaître les
à-coups et notamment vous m'interrogez
là dans les questions que vous m'avez
soumises sur ma mon choix de changer les
objectifs de la NA en mars 2016
très clairement en mars 2016 la date
devait faire 50 000 logements dans le
programme abitté mieux donc les publics
modestes je dis à Lana vous allez en
faire 70 000 et on met les moyens
financiers qui vont avec
et je à l'époque on est beaucoup à
penser qu'en fait s'il y a plus
d'impulsions et plus de budget ça suffit
à faire en réalité à la fin de l'année
ils feront 41 000 dossiers donc même pas
les 50 000 prévus et donc une incapacité
totale à
le faire et je vous cache pas que j'ai
été vraiment j'ai considéré ça comme un
échec patant pour moi pour les services
de l'État pour l'ensemble des ministères
et on a essayé de comprendre pourquoi en
réalité quand on décide en mars 2016 de
passer à 70 000
lanar repose donc certes une agence mail
repose sur des services qui sont soit
déconcentrés soit des centralisée avec
une délégation collectivité
les objectifs de 70 000 donc qui
augmentent les niveaux doivent être
redescendus dans les commits régionaux
de l'habitat de l'hébergement et de voté
c'est comme sur les aides à la pierre
puis après faut interroger les
collectivités pour savoir si elles vont
accompagner en co-financement les
projets supplémentaires et en réalité on
se rendra compte que pour beaucoup et
compréhenda une fois qu'on a fait le
premier ratio qui était prévu on va pas
plus loin et donc une incapacité à
travailler en flux à travailler au long
cours à commencer à engager des dossiers
et à les accompagner c'est aussi une
année et ça l'a expliqué il y a
plusieurs collectivités y compris
importante au niveau régional qui avait
changé de positionnement sur leur
accompagnement des dossiers de la NAS
qui a quand même été très préjudiciable
pour les pour les ménages et aussi très
clairement et ça avait été montré que
l'accompagnement financier n'était pas
suffisant en fait il y avait un reste à
charge trop important même dans les
programmes habités mieux qui étaient en
blocage très clairement pour les ménages
pour lancer les programmes
et que et donc il prenait pas le risque
mais c'est vrai que on est en 2023 le
budget de la nana n'est pas non plus
plus réel et je m'interroge toujours à
posteriori si on a réussi à le faire sur
la rue alors sur des sommes qui n'ont
rien à voir certes je regrette qu'on
puisse pas le faire sur la nappe l'autre
difficulté de l'ANAH de l'époque vous le
savez c'est que son budget était
construit avec la question des quotas
carbone donc moi j'ai pas eu de chance
je fais la période où en fait ils se
sont effondrés et je vous cache pas
comment garder tous les mois qu'elle
était le niveau d'écoute à carbone ce
qui fait qu'en fait plusieurs fois la
directrice de Lana m'appelait en me
disant je ne sais pas s'il combien de
dossiers je peux engager parce que ça va
des variations et qui objectivement leur
budget n'était pas pérennisé et je pense
que c'était
une des une des difficultés alors on y a
appris aussi de ça en 2017 d'une part on
a envoyé les programmations beaucoup
plus tôt à l'ensemble des des régions et
des préfets de région en février 2017 et
puis on a essayé de baisser la part du
quota carbone dans le budget de Lana
vous l'auriez compris en ponctionnant 50
millions à Action Logement je le dis ici
mais c'était aussi un moyen de trouver
une plus grande stabilité pour
l'accompagnement de ces ménages mais ça
explique en tout cas sur les sur ces
dossiers habités mieux qui était une
priorité pour tous de la difficulté à y
aller
l'autre chose après je m'arrêterai parce
que je suis un peu trop longue
au cours des années 2014-2015 2016 donc
y compris avec au moment de la
discussion de la loi pour la transition
énergétique et la croissance verte on
est aussi je vais le dire franchement le
secteur du bâtiment est pas totalement
prêt à la massification de la rénovation
on rénove en France j'ai retrouvé pour
travailler cette audition une étude
d'usiness de 2012 ou 2013 qui montre les
volumes de rénovation dans la période
précédente ça existe mais là on parle de
massifié et donc pour massifier il faut
s'appuyer sur l'ensemble des artisans
notamment on a beaucoup travaillé à
l'époque avec la CAPEP parce que c'est
un des sujets on a un type de
d'entreprise dans l'artisanat du
bâtiment qui est des petites entreprises
avec des enjeux de formation qui sont
pas évidentes parce que quand vous êtes
que deux ou trois dans chaque entreprise
vous vous formez pas aussi facilement
que ça et donc à la question du geste et
c'est pour ça qu'en fait en 2014 avec
Sylvia Pinel et j'ai ensuite moi fait en
place la suite on a travaillé sur trois
axes il y avait le BIM c'est-à-dire
enfin que l'ensemble des professionnels
du bâtiment s'adaptent à la question
numérique digitale et à la maîtrise du
BIM
vous avez bien vu qu'on n'y est pas
encore y compris la question du carnet
numérique du logement je crois vient
juste là de sortir alors que c'est dans
la loi 2015 il y avait la question de la
règle de l'art parce que le débat sur le
type de travaux la capacité à faire
est-ce que on pose correctement les
isolants les fenêtres et tout ça était
un sujet d'où le débat derrière sur la
question de RGE et donc la question de
la garantie pour avoir les projets
financés qui étaient qui étaient un
projet extrêmement important et c'est
vrai que ce que nous on a cherché à
l'époque c'est de d'essayer de créer un
écosystème qui pousse en fait l'ensemble
des opérateurs à être mieux formés et
accompagner cette massification
et je pense que c'est évidemment
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui un enjeu assez
assez important en fait pour pouvoir
pour pouvoir avancer
voilà donc vous l'aurez compris toute
façon quand on est ministre du Logement
je vous dis si on pense qu'on a un bon
bilan c'est qu'on a pas tout compris
parce que
j'ai jamais fini non mais faut être
extrêmement humble en fait
moi je pense qu'on a fait des choses
extrêmement intéressantes et qu'on a
posé les jaloux en fait de ce qui a
permis la suite et je parlerai si vous
le souhaitez évidemment des décisions
qui ont été prises par la suite mais oui
ça allait pas ça va pas ça n'allait pas
assez vite et ça ne va pas assez vite
aujourd'hui et et c'est en plus dans un
moment où en fait depuis 10 ans le
marché immobilier n'a jamais été aussi
florissant je pense que c'est ça aussi
qui est extrêmement compliqué c'est que
même si là il y a un petit coup d'arrêt
avec la loi climère résilience jusqu'à
jusqu'à cette année en fait n'importe
quel logement s'il est bien situé se
vend à des prix complètement dingues
quel que soit sa qualité énergétique ce
qui est fou ce qui est fou et ce qui
explique un problème et à côté de ça on
est encore face à des fléaux tel
l'habitat insalubre et indigne qui
demeure très important dans notre pays
qu'on n'a pas éradiquer et là notre
sujet n'est pas juste la question de du
DPE et de la classe énergétique c'est
vraiment autre chose donc je pense que
c'est aussi pour ça que même si beaucoup
de choses ont été faites et j'espère
seront poursuivis objectivement on
dirait que c'est un bilan un bilan
mitigé même si moi j'assume totalement
en fait
qu'on évolue avoir des objectifs pour
dire qu'en fait c'était le minimum qu'il
fallait faire tout d'abord pour répondre
à votre première question sur le lien
entre les deux ministères
ça renvoie plus largement aux problèmes
que rencontre le ministère de l'Écologie
de l'environnement enfin on l'appelle
comment il y a eu des
noms différents selon les périodes
en général
il y a un mot qui a la mode en ce moment
enfin une expression qui s'appelle la
charge mentale pas beaucoup de la charge
mentale et je trouve que ça s'applique
assez bien sur la question de du
ministère de en charge de l'écologie de
l'environnement
en gros traditionnellement c'est sur les
questions de climat sur les questions
d'environnement il y a eu une espèce de
tradition des autres ministères de
laisser la charge mentale de la
politique écologique du pays à ce
ministère et ça ça se traduisait de
manière assez évidente dans les fameuses
rimes les réunions interministérielles
que tout le monde connaît de nom en tout
cas qui sont des moments assez durs en
général pour les équipes du ministre en
charge de l'environnement parce que
c'est lui qui arrive en disant bah voilà
il y a tel ou tel objectif à respecter
et c'est cette voilà les mesures qu'il
faut mettre en place pour respecter cet
objectif et
traditionnellement tous les autres
ministères se liquide pour dire mais
c'est pas possible vous n'y pensez pas
il est à ce problème là ce problème là
ce problème là etc
et
ça il y a eu des évolutions je ne vais
certainement pas dire que rien ne se
passait et dans ces dernières années de
plus en plus de ministères et notamment
d'ailleurs avec l'arrivée du ministre de
Jean Castex à Matignon mais ça avait
déjà commencé avant Jean castèque
lui-même a impulsé dans les ministères
l'obligation de que chacun fasse ses
petites lettres pour expliquer ce qu'il
allait faire pour mettre en place des
mesures de transition écologique dans
son ministère donc ça évolué mais entre
ce qu'il faut faire et puis la culture a
changé c'est pas tout à fait la même
chose et alors que dans une rime on
devrait avoir ben voilà moi j'ai cet
objectif pour baisser les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre et tous les
ministères si dans un monde idéal où
tout le monde portrait la charge mentale
tous les ministères arriveraient en
disant bah moi sur mon domaine de
compétences j'essaye de ne surtout pas
en citer pour ne pas créer de problèmes
mais dans mon domaine de compétences
pour arriver à cet objectif je pourrais
faire ça ça et ça et moi je pourrais
faire ci je pourrais faire ça moi j'en
ai été témoin ça ne se passait pas comme
ça c'est à dire qu'à chaque fois c'était
vous n'y pensez pas et donc on avait
tous les ministères contre le ministère
de l'Environnement et dans ce cadre
avoir le ministère du Logement intégré
dans le ministère de l'Environnement ça
changeait tout parce que du coup le
ministère du Logement prenait sa part de
la charge mentale
j'ai pas dit qu'il ne prenait pas du
tout avant je dis que là simplement d'un
point de vue institutionnel c'était ça
l'obligeait à le faire y compris avec
les directions des ministères qui se
retrouvaient à travailler avec toutes
les autres de manière beaucoup plus
serrée donc c'est en ça que c'était
intéressant donc pour répondre à votre
question et c'est aussi pour ça que je
me suis battue à la fin de mon exercice
ministériel pour que
ce soit la première ministre le Premier
ministre je savais pas encore que ce
serait une première ministre que ce soit
le Premier ministre qui prennent
abra le corps c'est de charge mentale et
c'est pour ça que je suis ravie même si
après il va falloir que tout ça se
traduise des faits de manière
concrète on est au début d'un processus
mais je suis ravie que maintenant ce
soit la première ministre qui soit en
charge de la transition écologique que
il dit un secrétariat général à la
transition écologique spécifique qui
maintenant est supposée faire le travail
de d'un style cette charge mentale
partout
donc ça c'était la réponse à la première
question sur
l'arrêt du cite pour ma prime rénove
d'abord on avait un sujet du cite parce
que c'est un crédit d'impôt un crédit
d'impôt par définition même si on peut
avoir un chèque mais c'est quelque chose
qui
d'abord n'est distribué que l'année
d'après
donc on a un grand
[Musique]
pas entre le moment où on fait les
travaux et le moment où on peut
récupérer le crédit d'impôt pour un
certain nombre de ménages c'était
problématique parce que ils avaient pas
forcément la trésorerie pour le faire on
n'a pas résolu tous les problèmes avec
ma prime rénova j'en ai bien conscience
mais en théorie
la prime rénove permet très vite une
fois que les travaux ont été engagés de
pouvoir
lancer le processus pour pouvoir
recevoir la prime donc c'était quelque
chose qui se voulait plus proactif et
puis et puis il m'a pris me rénove
c'était le cite mais c'était aussi
d'autres aides qui étaient fusionnées
dans un dans ma prime rénove donc on
était sur vraiment une opération de
simplification alors j'entends vos
remarques monsieur rapporteur sur le
fait que chaque nouveau gouvernement
réinvente la poudre ou réinventer
je suis pas sûre même si je vois ce que
vous voulez dire mais
finalement tout ça est assez récent
le lancement de des grandes opérations
pour rénover les logements les bâtiments
d'un point de vue législatif c'est 2015
on est en 2023 c'est récent
à échelle à échelle politique c'est
assez récent même si le SPECT dont j'ai
parlé tout à l'heure de Picardie il
avait été mis en place bien avant mais
en Picardie on a toujours un petit peu
un petit peu en avance c'est comme ça
donc c'est assez récent et on doit aussi
tenir compte et c'est aussi le rôle
qu'on les parlementaire tenir compte de
des retours d'expérience et voir ce qui
a marché ce qui a pas marché clairement
les aides qu'on a mis en place étaient
trop compliquées trop trop lourd en
termes de de
d'accès
on pouvait pas faire comme si ça
n'existait pas et donc le fait de mettre
en place un guichet unique qui s'appelle
ma prime rénov avec un endroit unique où
aller chercher un site internet unique
où aller chercher c'était vraiment
l'idée de rendre ça beaucoup plus simple
et beaucoup plus accessible j'en profite
d'ailleurs pour dire que je pense qu'il
faudrait qu'on regarde de manière plus
plus clair sur le site aussi parce que
là j'y suis retourné par justement c'est
votre
votre réunion me permet m'a permis
d'aller jeter un oeil pour voir où ça en
été je pense qu'on a encore des
problèmes de de
d'accès parce que quand on va sur ma
prime rénov on n'est pas directement sur
France rénov hors France Renov c'est le
réseau justement c'est le réseau donc
c'est pas instinctif et mon
accompagnateur rénove que j'aime sur le
site ma prime rénov
il faut vraiment le chercher pour le
trouver et sur France rénov c'est pareil
on le trouve pas comme ça tout de suite
ce n'est pas proposé tout de suite moi
je crois que une des premières choses
qu'il faudrait faire c'est que sur ce
site
et après je parlerai des gens qu'on a au
téléphone mais sur ce site je pense
qu'il faudrait que tout de suite en
entrée de jeu y est cette proposition de
l'accompagnateur Renov il est
obligatoire d'accompagnateur Renov pour
certaines types de rénovation mais il
devrait être proposé tout de suite ça
devrait vous avez besoin qu'on vous aide
à faire votre diagnostic PAF directement
ça aujourd'hui ça n'y est pas et c'est
c'est un peu dommage à mon avis
sur sur le ce que vous disiez sur les
réseaux qui existent actuellement
comme je vous l'ai dit c'est pas à
l'échelle ce qui existe aujourd'hui et
très bien enfin il y a certains encore
une fois c'est inégal surtout sur des
territoires mais il y a vraiment
certains territoires où on a des des
systèmes qui sont bien et qu'il faut
saluer mais cela vont perdurer le
problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui on n'est
pas à l'échelle du tout
on n'est pas à l'échelle pour pouvoir
faire 700 000 rénovations par an c'est
ça mon sujet et vous pourrez faire tout
ce que vous voulez j'ai fait les fonds
de tiroirs des budgets et puis des
personnels publics de l'État ou des
collectivités on n'aura jamais assez de
monde compétent pour faire ça à
l'échelle donc si on veut passer à
l'échelle on doit recourir
on est tous dans le même bateau et on
est tous dans le même combat donc à un
moment on a intérêt à s'unir et à unir
nos forces là on a des gens qui sont
compétents qui peuvent nous aider on a
par exemple des architectes on a plein
de professions qui peuvent nous aider la
question et de les conventionner
sérieusement c'est à dire de faire un
vrai travail de de convention de
conventionnement d'agrément pour que
ils puissent y avoir aussi cette
restauration de la confiance j'ai pas
employé le terme de confiance jusque
maintenant on a aussi un problème de
déficit de confiance beaucoup de nos
concitoyens se sont fait arnaquer
parce que il y a eu des
dans les différentes primes qui étaient
proposées
il y a eu des effets d'aubaine qui ont
permis à certains professionnels non
scrupuleux de s'attaquer à nos
concitoyens c'est aussi pour ça
d'ailleurs qu'on a interdit maintenant
les appels téléphoniques sur la
rénovation énergétique le problème c'est
que beaucoup de considérés ne savent pas
donc il faut le redire que c'est
interdit et que si des personnes sont
sollicitées comme ça par téléphone il
faut qu'elle raccroche ou qu'elle dise
qu'elles vont appeler la police ou
qu'elles prennent les coordonnées de ces
gens pour prévenir les autorités
donc voilà c'est ça ma réponse c'est que
on a besoin de se mettre à l'échelle par
contre vous avez raison sur un point
très important c'est l'association des
collectivités d'ailleurs il est bien
prévu que l'accompagnateur renove soit
agréée par l'État ou désigné par une
collectivité locale donc les
collectivités locales sont tout à fait à
même de organiser leur réseau
et je crois que c'est aussi
par ce biais là qu'on doit montrer qu'on
est capable entre l'État des
collectivités locales de de bien
travailler ensemble pour que le réseau
soit le mieux maillé possible pour que
tous nos concitoyens puissent y avoir
accès donc ça c'est c'est l'idée et
c'est la manière dont moi je vois les
choses pour que ce soit mis en place de
la manière la plus efficace et
j'aimerais savoir aussi si votre
ministère a travaillé avec par exemple
celui de la culture qui est quand même
chargé de la protection de tous les
types de patrimoine en France ou alors
avec un ministère de l'Agriculture pour
pour développer on va dire des des
techniques de rénovation thermique
peut-être plus écologique plus le plus
local
merci
merci je sais pas si je
alors merci beaucoup pour pour ces
questions qui sont très importantes et
que je vous conseille si je peux me
permettre de vous donner un conseil de
poser également à Emmanuel vargon parce
que pour le coup elle s'est vraiment
elle qui s'est occupé de la réforme du
DPE de A à Z donc on a regardé ensemble
mais c'était vraiment elle qui était aux
manettes sur le sujet
bien sûr quand on a réfléchi à la
réforme du DPE mais pas seulement
d'ailleurs aussi quand on a réfléchi à
d'ailleurs la nouvelle réglementation
pour le pour les logements neufs on a
réfléchi à
d'abord à
essayer de repenser les qualifications
en repensant à des techniques
traditionnelles je crois que les
techniques traditionnelles ont été un
peu oubliées alors pour des raisons
simples c'est parce qu'on avait une
énergie bon marché et que donc ça
coûtait rien de de fabriquer des
logements qui étaient des passoires mais
on oublie que l'habitat traditionnel est
un habitat qui en général plutôt bien
adapté alors traditionnel avant les
années 50 et plutôt bien adapté aux
situations locales puisque c'était une
période où il fallait pas gâcher
gaspiller l'énergie donc
on a beaucoup à apprendre de nos anciens
de la même manière il y a eu un gros
travail qui a été fait sur
l'identification des des
de techniques et de et de matériaux qui
sont des mathés qui sont des matériaux
soit biosourcés
soit des matériaux dont qui étaient
regardés à l'aune de leur efficacité
énergétique et y compris aussi à l'aune
de leurs émissions de gaz à effet de
serre c'est aussi pour ça qu'on a eu
mais là je parle beaucoup plus sur sur
la question de l'aérone mais on a eu
beaucoup de difficultés avec le secteur
du béton qui considérait qu'on donnait
trop de place à
la filière bois d'une manière générale
mais parce que en termes de mission de
gaz à effet de serre enfin on est sur on
est sur vraiment des choses très
différentes
les programmes de recherche du Serena
ont été regardés ça j'en suis persuadé
mais vous demanderez encore une fois
confirmation à
Emmanuel wargon je ne voudrais pas dire
de bêtises à sa place les travaux avec
les autres ministères oui d'une manière
générale pas seulement sur ça mais ils
ont été
associés sur sur la loi climat et
résilience et sur cette partie se loger
évidemment après les ministères
étaient aussi proactifs mais il venait
nous voir
dois-je le dire publiquement mais si non
il venait plutôt nous voir pour nous
dire ce qui les embêté
dans la loi enfin je soyons clairs je
vous parlais tout à l'heure de la charge
mentale on a on avait des ministères
franchement ils ont tous essayé de jouer
le jeu
et je les salue en cela mais ils étaient
quand même sur un certain nombre de
sujets un peu
en fait à devoir lutter contre la
culture de leur ministère au départ
parce que moi je connais pas beaucoup de
ministères qui intégré la transition
écologique dans leur fondamentaux au
départ
et donc ça a été moi qui suis une
indéfectible optimiste on va dire que ça
a été un moyen de
de les sensibiliser encore plus et de
les faire participer la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments est absolument
indispensable si on veut être sur la
trajectoire climatique que nous nous
sommes fixés le bâtiment tout compris
quel que soit le type d'usage du
bâtiment c'est à peu près 45% de la
consommation finale d'énergie et c'est à
peu près un quart des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre
cette politique publique pour moi elle
est donc cruciale vous l'avez rappelé
j'ai été nommé secrétaire d'État à
l'écologie en octobre 2018 et assez vite
ça fait partie des sujets dont je me
suis emparée en tant que secrétaire
d'État sous l'égide de mon ministre de
tutelle de l'époque qui était François
de Rugy que j'ai continué à travailler
dans les périodes suivantes avec
Elisabeth borne puis avec barbara
Pompili comme ministre délégué au
logement donc c'est un sujet sur lequel
je pense avoir une forme de fil rouge ou
de continuité parce que je l'ai traité
pendant c'est presque quatre années de
présence ministérielle
ensuite c'est un sujet qui à mon avis ne
se règle pas ou pas majoritairement par
la loi c'est-à-dire on peut mettre tous
les objectifs législatifs qu'on veut on
peut mettre des chiffres dans les lois
successives la loi elle-même est pas
auto-réalisatrice et donc il suffit pas
de dire que on rénove 500 000 logements
par an dans la loi ou que il n'y aura
plus de password thermique 10 ans après
le vote du noir pour que tout ceci se
produise c'est un sujet qui est un sujet
de moyen d'exécution et de système
je vous ai apporté ce schéma que je vous
laisserai bien sûr quitter la manière
dont on pilotait ça au ministère et en
fait c'était extrêmement visuel c'est
c'est j'avais souhaité qu'on le fasse on
a des blocs de couleurs par type
d'actions à mener donc je vais vous les
détailler brièvement pour mener une
politique publique il faut la piloter
donc il faut déjà être capable de
compter donc d'avoir des chiffres et il
faut avoir une équipe qui la pilote
ça c'est notre bloc rouge piloter la
politique publique de rénovation
énergétique ensuite il faut des aides
qui fonctionnent qui soit accessible
efficace et juste il faut une filière
qui soit capable de répondre aux besoins
à la fois en compétence et en capacité à
faire et puis il faut de
l'accompagnement puisque les aides
toutes seules ne suffisent pas et c'est
vraiment comme ça que j'ai travaillé
avec mon équipe avec les administrations
en essayant vraiment de
de travailler sur l'ensemble des
éléments du système un peu comme comme
de l'horlogerie comme les rouages d'une
montre si vous voulez que ça fonctionne
il faut que chaque rouage fonctionne
d'individuellement et puis après quand
vous assemblez et ben si tout va bien la
montre finit par fonctionner et par vous
donner l'heure
je vais commencer par le pilotage parce
que c'est pas forcément le point qui
était le plus connu mais c'était un
point important
quand j'ai commencé à m'occuper de cette
politique publique j'ai fait deux
constats en la matière le premier c'est
qu'il y avait pas d'équipe en charge et
le deuxième c'est que personne ne
comptait rien du tout alors il y avait
pas d'équipe en charge ça n'est pas
faire un jour du tout aux équipes
ministérielles il y avait beaucoup de
direction d'administration centrale
concernées d'abord c'était un sujet
interministériel entre le ministère du
Logement d'un côté qui était à l'époque
rattaché au ministère des collectivités
territoriales et le ministère de
l'Écologie de l'autre donc pour que ça
fonctionne il fallait un accord entre
les deux ministres et pendant toute la
première période j'ai travaillé en
grande proximité avec Julien de
Normandie qui était à l'époque ministre
du Logement
ensuite on avait donc deux
administrations d'un côté
l'administration du logement la Dhu P la
direction de l'Habitat de l'Urbanisme et
de l'autre la direction de l'énergie et
du climat qui avait à ce corps donné sur
ces politiques publiques et elle se
coordonnait plus ou moins bien ce qui
veut dire que à peu près toutes les
décisions remontées au cabinet au
pluriel et au ministre au pluriel donc
ça m'a pris un an pour créer une
délégation interministérielle une équipe
en charge du pilotage de la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments qu'on est au
moins un petit nombre de personnes dans
la République qui se lèvent le matin
avec comme mission d'être en charge de
faire progresser la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments et nous
l'avons fait et ça a été en fait
relativement long et relativement
compliqué
ensuite sur la capacité à produire des
données à les analyser là aussi on
n'avait pas un seul chiffre un peu carré
sur combien est-ce qu'on a de password
thermique quelle est la qualité quel est
le l'efficacité individuelle d'un geste
de rénovation quelle est l'efficacité de
chacune des aides l'une ou l'autre donc
j'ai demandé au CGDD le Commissariat
général du développement durable de
monter un observatoire national de la
rénovation énergétique ce qu'il a fait
mais aussi ça a pris un certain temps ce
qui nous a amené une étude qui recalait
une bonne fois le nombre de passoires
thermiques et maintenant le chiffre qui
fait fois et qui a aussi mené des
travaux sur le nombre de gestes en
essayant de recoller les différents
éléments provenance de différentes
sources c'est très important parce que
vous pouvez pas mener une politique
publique si vous n'avez pas d'un côté
une équipe qui est en charge et de
l'autre un endroit dans lequel vous
pouvez
observer la réalité
si j'arrive aux aides on avait à
l'époque beaucoup d'aides qui
relevait de logique extrêmement
différente en fait il y avait en gros
trois grands types d'aides le premier
c'était les aides historiques de Lana
des aides extrêmement qualitatives
plutôt tournées vers la rénovation
globale très liée aux collectivités
territoriales et avec un volume
extrêmement faible puisque deux mémoires
et donc
j'ai pas les chiffres parce que je suis
plus en charge mais l'ordre de grandeur
c'était de l'ordre de 30000 en gros
aident annuels sur le programme abitté
mieux sérénité que tu es vraiment le
programme de rénovation globale et un
peu moins sur les aides un peu plus
simples donc ces aides étaient dans une
certaine logique de sur mesure mais on
parle de 30000 peut-être 40 000
rénovations accompagnées par an donc un
volume finalement extrêmement faible
deuxième source d'aide qui était en
train de se développer de façon assez
peu pilotée c'était l'utilisation des
C2E des certificats d'économie d'énergie
c'était le début de la montée en charge
des certificats d'économie d'énergie et
à peu près au moment où je suis arrivé
François de Rugy a lancé sous sa propre
initiative les rénovations à 1 euro les
combles à 1 euro etc essentiellement
financé par des C2E est totalement non
piloté nationalement pas très peu piloté
nationalement donc on a eu une explosion
du volume de ces deux œufs mais sur des
sur des gestes
pas vraiment suivi pas vraiment piloté
pas vraiment contrôlé et puis la
troisième source d'aide c'était le cite
qui mais je pense que ça a été beaucoup
dit mais je vais le redire est un crédit
d'impôt qui était versé 18 mois après et
qui avait comme caractéristique
d'adverser à 50% aux deux plus haut des
cils de revenus c'était une aide quand
même totalement anti redistributive
c'est-à-dire si on considère que le
budget est également réparti la moitié
de l'aide à aller au 20% les plus riches
et qui est par ailleurs était une aide
qui allait essentiellement au
financement du changement de fenêtre
dont je crois qu'on est tous d'accord
pour dire que c'est pas le geste de
rénovation le plus efficace
et qui est comme il était versé un an et
demi après difficile de dire s'il était
incitatif ou pas c'était quand même
assez largement un effet d'Open et ces
trois aides étaient dans trois univers
de politique publique très différents le
premier ministère du Logement très lié à
l'action locale des collectivités ça
c'est un point très positif c'était les
aides de Lana la deuxième les C2E en
fait l'outil du ministère de l'écologie
pour faire de la rénovation énergétique
mais avec une confiance à mon avis un
peu forte dans les systèmes de
régulation des acteurs privés et
d'ailleurs on a eu énormément de fraudes
énormément d'abus et on a fini par
arrêter les aides à 1 euro parce qu'on
considérait que l'isolation à 1 euro ou
les combles à 1 euro étaient porteuses
de trop défaites pervers
et puis le crédit d'impôt qui avait
peut-être été obtenu un jour par le
ministère de l'écologie mais qui n'était
pas du tout piloté par le ministère de
l'écologie qui d'ailleurs n'était pas
piloté du tout
face à ça dans une période
de recherche d'économies budgétaire
le Premier ministre de l'époque Édouard
Philippe a souhaité qu'on restreigne
beaucoup le montant du cice et c'est le
moment où on a décidé de tenter de le
transformer en prime et donc on l'a
transformé en ma prime rénov avec un
budget qui avait été divisé par deux
alors c'était pas mon choix et
évidemment comme tout membres du
gouvernement qui se respecte je m'étais
battu pour avoir des meilleurs
arbitrages budgétaires
mais l'argumentation était pas très
facile à faire parce que c'était pas
totalement évident de démontrer que le
cite atteignait sa cible et que il était
vraiment performant et donc l'arbitrage
du Premier ministre était un peu fondé
sur l'idée fait une aide montrer qu'elle
marche montrer qu'elle cible les bons
publics et les bons gestes et on verra
après pour la montée en puissance de
cette aide et c'est ce qui s'est passé
puisqu'on a démarré ma primera novembre
collectivement entre le ministère du
Logement et le ministère de l'Écologie
de l'époque puisque c'était encore avec
Julien de Normandie donc les deux
ministres l'ont porté
on l'a démarré pardon
sur le passage du cite à la prime rénov
vous dans votre volonté c'était plutôt
quoi de rester au départ sur du cite et
ensuite il y a eu l'arbitrage pour être
sur une prix rénov vous vous étiez moi
j'ai très vite été convaincu qu'il
fallait que on fasse converger les trois
outils dont je vous parlais et que du
coup le passage à une aide qui serait
versé immédiatement après la fin des
travaux qui seraient mieux ciblés sur
les travaux et plus redistributif serait
mieux en revanche on avait un budget
d'environ 2 milliards pour le cite et
évidemment j'ai plaidé pour qu'on ait le
même budget donc 2 milliards sur la
nouvelle aide qui est devenu ma prime
rénov
donc le fait que le budget a été divisé
par deux au moment où on est passé du
cite à ma prime rénov c'était pas mon
souhait pas le choix du ministère dans
lequel j'étais et pas le souhait du
ministère du logement non plus en
revanche
moi j'ai passé beaucoup de temps à
essayer de rapprocher les aides de Lana
cette nouvelle aide qui est une aide
directe qui avait l'immense avantage
d'être versée beaucoup plus rapidement
et laisser deux œufs pour ne pas avoir
trois politiques publiques juxtaposées
avec trois outils juxtaposés qui
répondaient pas aux mêmes exigences
techniques qui couvraient pas le même
type de travaux avec pas le même type
d'exigence sur les entreprises et du
coup en fait trois mini politiques de la
rénovation énergétique des logements
mais une seule politique de rénovation
énergétique des logements on a créé ma
prime rénov début 2020
en
organisant mieux le lien entre les
gestes et des par ma prime rénov et la
manière dont les C2E pouvait s'y adosser
ce qui veut dire que pour un ménage
bénéficiaire ménage pouvait bénéficier à
la fois de ma prime rénove et de ces
deux œufs sur la même opération ce qui
voulait dire d'avoir exactement les
mêmes critères sur le changement de
chaudière ou l'isolation ou des
opérations plus riches je reviendrai à
la question un seul geste ou plusieurs
gestes qui évidemment une question
importante dans la discussion donc on
l'a créé début 2020 juste avant le début
du covid
du coup
on était évidemment
très inquiet du fait que cette aide
trouve son public en période de crise
elle l'a néanmoins fait et du coup on a
réussi à faire 250.270
000 dossiers de mémoire en 2020 puis 700
000 en 2021 à peu près autant en 2022
ce qui est intéressant et ça c'est l'un
des outils de l'Observatoire de la
rénovation énergétique c'est qu'on a
mesuré
l'économie moyenne d'énergie entre un
logement aidé par le cite et un logement
aidé par ma prime rénov parce que c'est
évidemment l'un des critères on gagne
combien en énergie et après ça se
convertit en CO2 on a multiplié par deux
on est passé de 2,5 mégawh par logement
avec le cite à 5,3
mégawattheure par an par logement avec
ma prime rénov ce qui était l'un des
critères de performance le plan de
relance nous a aidé puisque la première
année m'a pris me rénov avait à peu près
un milliard de budget et qu'ensuite le
plan de relance est arrivé et qu'on a
décidé de cibler une partie des crédits
du plan de relance sur ma prime rénov
sachant que vous savez commencer dans
une négociation budgétaire pour savoir
comment limiter une aide dans une
enveloppe
toute la question est autour des
critères des montants unitaires et des
liligibilité et donc plus on avait le
moyen plus on était capable d'avoir des
gestes correctement aidés et d'aider les
différentes catégories de ménage et on a
réussi à calibrer ça à peu près bien
ma prime rénov est inversement
proportionnelle aux revenus donc en gros
il y a quatre catégories de ménage le
ménage les plus modestes sont les plus
aisés pour moi il était très important
d'aider néanmoins tous les ménages donc
y compris le car le plus favorisé avec
des montants plus bas et avec des
montants notamment plus bas sur les
monogestes en aidant plutôt uniquement
sur la rénovation globale mais quand
même pour pouvoir dire que cette aide
était universelle parce que finalement
c'est l'une des grandes questions les
émissions de CO2 elles sont partout
elles sont chez les ménages modestes
mais elles sont aussi chez les ménages
les plus aisés
et c'est pour ça qu'il me touche je
trouvais que c'était un bon équilibre
d'aider plus ceux qui en ont le plus
besoin mais c'était quand même un peu
tout le monde ma prime rénov est
beaucoup plus redistributif puisque plus
de la moitié va au ménage les plus
modestes donc ça c'est sur la partie
aide et on a passé beaucoup de temps à
regarder les fiches C2E pour être sûr
qu'elles étaient alignées avec les
fiches map Prim rénov et que du coup on
aimait bien de façon coordonnée
et puis est arrivé évidemment la
question de l'accompagnement et des
guichets là aussi moi j'ai trouvé une
situation très éclatée et je pense
qu'elle est encore donc surtout ces
sujets je considère que on a progressé
dans les quatre dernières années mais je
évidemment je n'irai pas jusqu'à dire
que le sujet est complètement réglé que
le système fonctionne parfaitement bien
je pense qu'on a encore des progrès à
faire sur la partie guichet
on avait vraiment deux univers qui se
parlaient pas du tout entre les guichets
de Lana et les guichets de l'ADEME voir
des guichets de collectivités
territoriales portées appuyer ni par
l'un ni par l'autre
au point que mon expression a été de
dire qu'il fallait être bilingue Ana
Adem et que ça parlait à peu près tous
mes interlocuteurs
Lana partait soit de l'aide au ménage
très modeste soit de partenariats très
sur mesure avec des collectivités
l'ADEME partait plutôt
d'aide un petit peu plus globale
en accompagnant aussi des guichets de
façon complètement séparée de Nana et du
coup j'ai passé ces quatre années à
essayer de rapprocher les deux univers
donc on sait demander pendant assez
longtemps qu'elle était la bonne manière
d'organiser quel était l'opérateur qui
allait pouvoir porter ça le mieux
on avait commencé avec l'ADEME parce que
la dame est un interlocuteur plus
naturel des régions or les régions
étaient par la loi à chargées du service
public de l'efficacité énergétique de
l'habitat
et nous avons soutenu les collectivités
à travers un programme C2E dédié qui
s'appelait SAR et du coup ce programme
était porté par l'ADEME néanmoins la
connaissance fine à l'échelle communale
intercommunale était vraiment côté Anna
le partenariat sur mesure était plutôt
côté Anna et après quelques années à
tâtonner on nous avons décidé de tout
rapatrier à Lana considérant que c'était
l'agence de l'amélioration de l'habitat
et que même si sa compétence initiale
était plutôt sur l'habitat indigne et
les ménages les plus en difficulté elle
était en capacité d'avoir une action
universelle et puis elle portait le
guichet map primanov donc c'était
logique que la nappe aussi les guichets
d'accompagnement
donc un travail de précision avec
transfert des équipes progressif
responsabilité intégrale donnée à Lana
et cohérence entre les aides et les
guichets et c'est là dessus que nous
avons ajouté la création de France rénov
c'est-à-dire la labellisation de
guichets de tous les guichets existants
d'appui à la rénovation énergétique
et du coup
l'homogénéisation enfin la capacité à ce
que c'est guichet réussissent à porter
la même politique publique nationale
complétée ou au service des politiques
locales quand il y en avait moi j'avais
été très frappé par une visite que
j'avais faite en Haute-Saône quelque
part courant 2000 fin 2019
ou
j'étais allée voir un guichet Anna qui
fonctionnait très bien ensuite j'étais
allée voir un chantier de rénovation
dans un ancien moulin qui était avec une
rénovation globale financée par la
Région donc Bourgogne Franche-Comté
et en fait ce guichet face ce moulin qui
était en cours de rénovation avait
bénéficié de l'aide d'Anna et donc avait
dû faire un certain nombre de diagnostic
et de dossiers pour Lana et puis il
avait aussi été candidat à une aide de
la région qui était baquée sur la dame
il a fallu tout refaire parce que les
diagnostics n'étaient pas les mêmes les
experts n'étaient pas les mêmes en fait
les deux systèmes étaient complètement
disjoints et c'était lié au fait que il
y avait pas une entente parfaite entre
le département et la région à l'époque
entre le service départemental et le
service régional j'y mets pas de
politique mais plutôt une coordination
qui s'était pas vraiment faite donc on a
tenté de recréer cette coordination avec
le programme d'accompagnement à la
rénovation énergétique SAR qui donnait
des moyens supplémentaires à l'échelle
régionale et de faire monter l'ANA comme
interlocuteur de proximité des
collectivités
essentiellement commune et
intercommunalité dans certains cas
départements mais c'est vraiment très
variable il y a des départements qui
s'investissent et des départements qui
s'investissent pas du tout et régions
qui de toute façon ont la compétence
cette ce maillage est pas complètement
fini il y a plein d'endroits dans
lesquels la répartition des compétences
et donc des publics si je peux dire même
si c'est pas une expression très
heureuse et pas très claire
et l'idée de France Renov c'était
vraiment que chacun ait accès à un
guichet un guichet physique
quel que soit sa situation et quel que
soit ses revenus
avec Frank raynov est arrivé mon
accompagnateur Renov donc la même idée
de dire que
les aides c'est bien mais que le besoin
d'accompagnement est important on part
quand même d'un crédit d'impôt dans
lequel le concept même d'accompagnement
n'existe pas un crédit d'impôt c'est
vous dépensez comme vous voulez vous
mettez une facture en pièce jointe de
votre déclaration d'impôts et vous avez
une aide défalquée de vos impôts ou un
crédit d'impôt si vous payez pas
d'impôts donc l'idée de dire il faut
vraiment arriver à dosser maintenant les
aides à un accompagnement avec la montée
en puissance de mon accompagnateur Renov
donc ce que ce que je vous retrace c'est
un cheminement qui est en fait pas
uniquement poussé par les lois
successives et qui rencontre la
convention citoyenne pour le climat dont
vous parliez dans votre propos
introductif
mais qui avait déjà commencé et qui
a passé une étape supplémentaire avec
cette convention
alors je vous ai parlé du pilotage je
vous ai parlé des données je vous ai
parlé des aides et de l'accompagnement
évidemment dans une politique publique
classique mais je vous apprendrai rien
on balance entre des incitations et des
contraintes et toute la question est de
trouver le bon mix entre les deux
sur les passoires thermiques locatif
moi j'étais assez convaincue que on ne
ferait pas sans contrainte parce que
autant pour un propriétaire occupant
il ou elle et lui-même directement
concerné par l'État d'isolation de son
logement et donc potentiellement motiver
quand même par le fait de faire des
travaux autant pour un propriétaire
bailleur c'est pas le propriétaire
bailleur qui subit le fait qu'une
passoire thermique est une passoire
thermique et donc même si on a ouvert
les aides aux propriétaires bailleurs
c'était l'une des avancées de ma prime
rénov j'étais assez convaincue que ça ne
suffirait pas et qu'il faudrait passer
par une contrainte et au moment de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat la
question c'est d'ailleurs posée de
savoir si les obligations de rénovation
des passeports thermiques il fallait les
poser sur tout le monde donc y compris
les propriétaires occupants ou
uniquement sur les propriétaires
bailleurs et il me semble que la
convention citoyenne voulait aller
au-delà des propriétaires bailleurs
moi j'ai considéré que poser une
obligation c'était déjà lourd et
important et que cette obligation elle
avait plus de sang sur les propriétaires
bailleurs parce qu'encore une fois vous
êtes d'ailleurs de toute façon votre
logement vous le louez vous touchez
votre loyer donc le simple fait d'être
éligible à une aide vous motive pas
forcément pour engager des travaux
sachant que vous n'êtes pas pénalisé par
le fait que les factures sont
extrêmement élevées ou que les logements
sont extrêmement difficiles à chauffer
d'où cette obligation de rénovation des
passoires thermiques pour la mise en
location progressive donc c'est la
première base de l'obligation était déjà
dans la loi énergie climat pour les
passoires les plus significatives elle a
été très très fortement renforcé dans la
loi climat et résilience
ma position était de le faire que sur
les f et léger lorsque pour moi le sujet
sont vraiment les passoires thermiques
et donc les E mais je pense que barbara
Pompili avait vu vous le dire c'était
plutôt la position de barbara Pompili
j'étais pas hostile mais je considérais
que le
l'important c'était de faire FG après ce
qu'on l'a fait trop vite est-ce que les
dates sont tenables on était avant la
guerre en Ukraine enfin on passait d'une
crise à l'autre bien sûr mais enfin on
sortait du covid on était avant la
guerre en Ukraine à un moment où le prix
des matériaux avait pas explosé
j'ai toujours pensé que ce genre de
politique en fait d'abord il faut donner
un signal clair et qu'ensuite il est
déjà arrivé au Parlement et au
gouvernement de décaler de quelques mois
des dates d'application quand le signal
est donné mais que la date d'application
n'apparaît pas possible et donc c'est
quelque chose qu'on pourrait le cas
échéant desserrer un peu
de mon point de vue le signal est là de
mon point de vue c'est pas une mauvaise
nouvelle qu'il y ait beaucoup de
passoires thermiques en vente parce que
pour moi c'est plus une mauvaise
nouvelle quand un appartement donné ou
une maison donnée est vendue au même
prix que ce soit un G ou que ce soit un
B parce que l'acheteur dans un cas
n'aura pas de travaux à faire et dans
l'autre va être obligé de faire des
travaux importants juste pour isoler son
bien immobilier donc le signal soit dans
le marché et que du coup les biens mal
isolés coûte moins cher
proportionnellement ce qui veut dire que
quand vous achetez vous savez que vous
achetez avec un investissement
complémentaire à faire la banque vous
finance aussi pour cet investissement me
paraît plutôt une bonne nouvelle
si le rythme va bien et si on arrive à
faire faire les travaux ce qui mène à
tout le temps que j'ai pas encore cité
de la montée en compétences de la
filière
[Musique]